union européenne est en pleine
discussion concernant la politique
agricole commune la réforme pour une pac
plus verte doit s'appliquer à partir de
janvier 2023
et c'est pour faire pression sur les
négociations en cours que les
agriculteurs du grand est ont convergé
aujourd'hui vers le parlement européen
un défilé de plus d'un millier de
tracteurs dans les rues de strasbourg ce
qui a occasionné d'importants
embouteillages
les syndicats agricoles redoutent
notamment certaines à mesure qu'ils
soumettent les aides à des critères
environnementaux ils dénoncent aussi les
rotations imposer des cultures qui selon
eux amènera une baisse des fourrages à
proximité des fermes
je vous propose d'écouter philippe
clément pour secrétaire général a fait
mais cela grand test
ce qui est en train de se décider en
fait c'est une décroissance de
l'agriculture qui va conduire à terme en
fait les importations denrées
alimentaires bien plus importante que ce
qu'elle ne pourrait être aujourd'hui
alors qu'on avait nous confère une
grosse sur notre territoire aujourd'hui
nous leur disons surtout faites
confiance à vos paysans et si nous
devons effectivement encore aller un peu
plus loin dans tout ce qui est
environnemental pression écologiste sur
nos exploitations non dit ok c'est ce
qu'on fait depuis un certain nombre de
thons déjà mais ça ne pourra pas se
faire sans revenu et sans accompagnement